les tests sont allées très vite désir
soit on a appris que la jeune française
hospitalisés à montpellier pour une
suspicion de grippe aviaire n'avait pas
été contaminées par le virus
en fait c'est une illustration grandeur
nature de la procédure mise en place par
le ministère de la santé pour que le
dépistage se fasse au plus vite en cas
de doute
florence mavic suspicion du virus h5n1
ou mauvaise grippe hivernale l'alerté
sanitaire s'est immédiatement déclenchée
première étape samedi les urgentistes de
l'hôpital de sète dans lequel la
patiente est venu en consultation des
sites son transfert vers le centre
hospitalier de montpellier
seul le samu est habilitée pour cette
mission de véhicules est une ambulance
confiné qui a qu'une personne qui
s'occupe du patient dans la cellule
arrière et donc qui est habillé avec des
masses une un masque des lunettes et
puis une combinaison stériles aussi est
par contre les chauffeurs de l'ambulance
sont devant simplement ils essaient de
la voir aucun contact avec la personne
potentiellement contaminés
deuxième étape la passion se retrouve
dans une chambre isolée
commence alors une série de tests le
protocole mis au point par les autorités
sanitaires est le même pour toute la
france
un premier test de dépistage est négatif
mais conformément aux procédures des
prélèvements au niveau du nez et de la
gorge sont alors envoyés dans un
laboratoire marseillais diagnostic final
hier soir pas de trace du virus mortel
la mobilisation médical a semble-t-il
bien fonctionné nous allons tirer tous
les enseignements de cet épisode aussi
pour essayer d'améliorer encore un peu
les choses parce que la menace n'est pas
écartée elle est réelle et sérieuse
et donc elle nécessite que nous
préparions encore davantage cette alerte
n'est pas une première en france on ce
cas ont déjà fait l'objet de tests tous
se sont révélés négatifs